(hip hop instrumental music)
- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is the Ask Gary Vee Show live
in our London office at VaynerMedia.
We have a audience in front of us.
You guys can clap real quick.
(audience applauses)
And as you can tell, I
have a very attractive,
athletic looking man to the
right of me, left for you,
- Thank you.
- and so I'm gonna allow him
to, you're welcome.
I'm gonna allow him to,
I'm gonna try not to look at
your pretty blue eyes too much.
Why don't you introduce
yourself to the live audience
and the audience watching at home?
Create a little context.
I've got a couple of questions.
We'll open it up to the
audience, and we'll do our thing.
- Alright, so, thank you,
everybody, for coming.
My name is Daniel Williams.
I play for Huddersfield Town,
it's in the Premier League,
and I used to play for
Reading for four years.
Before I was at Reading,
I used to play in Germany
for Hoffenheim and for Freiburg,
and my dad is American, my mom is German,
but I was born and raised
in Germany, as you can hear.
But I played for the US
national team as well,
and that's all about it, really.
- So, let's take it way back.
Obviously this episode's
a lot of fun for me
for many, many different reasons.
One, being in the UK
office is a lot of fun.
Two, I'm on this quest to discover
what is going to be my proper
football team that I support,
and we'll get--
(audience shouting)
The Spurs are in a very big lead,
I'll give you the details on that.
Obviously we're coming on
the back of the World Cup,
the US did not make it.
I have a son that I'm excited
to get into proper football,
the culture of proper football.
E-sports is exploding.
It takes me back to my thesis of why
football is popping in America,
in comparison to all the other times
because of a game galled
FIFA that came out for
Sega Genesis in 94.
There's a lot of places
I wanna go with you,
from your perspective, for my audience,
which is more marketing and business
and things of that nature,
but before we get into all of that,
I'd like to set a little
bit more context with you.
How did your football career start?
So, you were born in Germany?
- I was born in Germany.
- And what happens?
Immediately, you have
a football by your foot
'cause your dad liked it,
or how did it go down?
- Well, not so much my
dad because he's American.
- So, your grandfather on your mom's side?
(laughs)
- So, when I was, I think, three years,
my mom gave me a football,
and my dad, he was like,
"What are you doing?"
I wanted to play basketball
or American football or whatever,
and yeah, I said to him, listen--
- Did he not know he was in Germany?
(laughs)
- Well, I don't know, I
think he still misses home.
But he never went back
because he's so scared to fly.
- Hold on, hold on.
(audience laughter)
- No, seriously, he never
went back to the States.
- No, but I need this because
this is gonna clearly be
the best part of this episode.
One more time,
where was your dad from in the US?
- He's from New York.
- Okay, so your dad, who's from New York,
you're telling me that
somehow he got to Germany,
probably on a plane.
- Yes.
- Yeah,
but after a little while, he
became so fearful of flying
that he's never gone back
'cause he's scared to fly?
- Yeah, well, so, he was
in the US Army, like--
- This is getting better.
- Exactly, like yeah.
All the Americans know,
and we're mixed race kids
from Germany--
- Yes.
- The women like the black
guys there, whatever.
(laughter)
And then he came back,
and yeah, so, the minute he
came back the second time,
my mom, she was like, "Listen,
you need to stay here,
"I will not let you go again,"
and then basically it started.
And ever since, he stayed in Germany.
He told me many times that he regrets it,
that he stayed in Germany because
(laughter)
his biggest dream was
to live in California
but he met my mom, and they had me.
And then all of a sudden, he stayed there,
and that's the story.
- And he's still in Germany right now?
- He's sill in Germany
- And how old's your dad?
- He is born in 58, so
he's, how old is he?
50, yeah.
- So, 60?
- 60, sorry, yeah.
- That's okay.
(audience laughter)
Some play football, some do math.
I mean, I know how it works.
(laughter)
So, so wait.
So, fine, so, you get a ball at three,
your mom puts it by your foot, and what?
You gravitate towards it immediately?
- Yeah, I mean, the local
sport, the favorite sport
I think in Europe--
- Of course.
- Is football or soccer.
- You guys in the States call it--
- I call it proper football, so.
(laughter)
- And you have all the kids stay,
they stay out late and
play, play football,
and then you're just
throwing it, and then--
- And were you good at it right away?
Were you always naturally good,
or did you have a spurt at some point?
- No, I was confident in kicking the ball,
but then I grew up with
all the people next to me
and then it was like we played football
and I was still better than them.
And then they told me, "Danny, listen,
"I think you should join a
team, like another team."
My mom supported it and then
I went down and they
told me, "Listen, Danny,
"you're a bit too fat, you're chubby.
"I think you have to eat less chocolate.
"Come off this pride and all this stuff,
"and come back in a year."
So I did that actually and
then I came back within a year,
and yeah, I think I started
my first training session--
- How old were you then?
- I was maybe like five,
I would say, five, six,
it's like young, young.
- Clearly.
(laughter)
- So we started then, and I was--
- This is why Germany is
good at proper football.
They tell five year olds to
stop eating fucking chocolate.
- Yeah, I know, that's
Germany, like crazy.
And I went back and ever since,
I was lucky that the
local team must have had,
the first team was already
in the bonus league,
I don't know what they call it in Germany
and so I grew up, and grew and grew,
and then obviously I went under 10, 11,
and then when I was under 15,
I got called up by the
German national team,
and then it got quite
serious because I knew,
okay, you're selected for the best players
in Germany--
- Before you got called up
for that, did you have a sense
that you could play at the highest levels?
Or were you still young,
insecure, trying to be humble?
Before that, which had become
so obvious, it's undeniable,
take me to the year before
that, did you have a sense,
or were you just aloof or
were you focused on it,
where was your mindset
before that call up?
- Before the call up,
I was quite confident
because I clearly saw
that it's easy for me
to compete against one or two
year older players, right?
And--
- That were good players.
- They were good players,
but then when I made it
to the German under 15's,
and I remember there were
players like Thomas Muller
and then I started to be like, okay.
I don't know if I can make it,
but stay focused and whatever.
And yeah, it helped me a lot
because out of these insecurities,
taught me to train harder
and got out of it less,
started 16 and 17 and those hit
the wall and all that stuff,
as the guys know and--
(audience laughter)
So, but yeah, then when I was 15,
I got this invitation from Freiburg,
which is the best youth academy,
I would say, in Germany.
And my parents, they told me,
"Danny, I think you should
take this opportunity,"
because went from a lot
of my friends back then,
they drifted apart and
I don't know, was important--
- Started hitting you
with the question?
- Yeah, it was a little
bit of a rough upbringing.
So for my development
as a football player,
it was the best because I live there,
they pay for my school, they pay for food,
they pay for everything, and my parents
didn't really have to
worry about me anymore.
And yeah, so I had this
education from 15 to 19,
and I learned a lot in those years.
- Before we get into
questions and before I switch
the topic to things around
the sport and marketing
and the tension and other things
that I like to talk about,
when you think about
your professional career,
what are the one or two things
that stand out the most?
- Definitely my first
game, which was on TV
because I could just see
my parents in the crowd,
and they were crying and everything,
so I was like, I better not fuck this up.
(laughter)
But I was--
- Were you crazy nervous?
- I was so nervous, I didn't
sleep the night before,
I had to go to toilet, I
don't know, 20, 30 times
during the day because--
- Your stomach was just fucked up.
- My stomach was almost
like now open, like a--
(laughter)
But so I had to, I don't
know, try to focus again,
but it was a big day
because when I was playing
for Freiburg, Stuttgart,
and that's a big rivalry they have and--
- So right out the gate,
your first match is
a big rivalry match.
- Yes, it was the Friday
night game as well,
and still got the head
players like Alexander Lamp,
Sami Khedira, Pablo Pretnia, like the pro,
loaded players, that
was like, I would say,
I'm 29, but it's almost 10 years ago,
and so I was--
- How did you play?
- The first 5, 10 minutes,
I remember blood pounding
and I was just diving on the front,
just like please someone
pass me, but it was so good,
and then after 10 minutes, I settled down
and took a deep breath or whatever,
and I just talked to
myself, listen, enjoy it.
You have 25,000 people watching you
and all your friends that watch you on TV,
and where I'm from,
not a lot of people get
the opportunity to make it.
- Make it out.
- So I thought, you know what?
Danny, it's not that bad, even
if you make a few mistakes,
it's your first game, I
mean, come on, it's normal.
And then, yeah, that was definitely
one of the proudest moments,
and I would say another proud
moment was when we played
against Brazil--
- Yes.
- With the States and I
scored a goal against Brazil.
Every kid dreams about playing
against Brazil or Spain,
like England and all of that,
so that was a proud, proud moment.
And I remember I was
playing against Neymar,
and the funny story to it is that for me,
I used to play with him in Hoffenheim,
he just got called up to
the Brazil national team,
so yeah, it was quite
intense, but I was very proud.
- That's awesome.
Talk to me about now you
as a person in a category
that I love a lot, which is social media.
Obviously I've looked at your
Instagram and things of that
nature, where do you today
sit with social media?
What do you use, what do you like?
How do you like it, how
do you think about it?
How do you think about it as an athlete?
How do you think about it as a guy?
How do you think about it?
- Well, there's a lot of advantages
and a lot of disadvantages, of course.
But--
- What are the advantages?
(laughter)
- Advantages, the women.
No, no. (laughs)
- Just wanna hear
what people say.
- No, no, just kidding.
- No, you're not kidding.
You are definitely not kidding.
- No. (laughs)
- That may promise everyone.
- No, I mean, you can, (laughs)
I mean, we are quite like,
I'm a public person, right?
People already know us from
playing the Premier League,
and they see us on TV or whatever.
And some people, they judge
you by the way you look
or whatever.
- Sure.
- And what I like about
social media is that
you can actually show
yourself on a different side,
other interests you have, maybe
fashion or whatever, right?
And also, you can still control
what you want people to see,
because I would not necessarily put
me with my family or whatever in that
because at the end of the
day, it's social media.
- It's, you're in control, right?
You're in control about
painting a more complete
picture about yourself.
You're in control that it's not
somebody commentating on you
and your play and your social
life, it's you projecting it.
What platforms do you use?
- I use Instagram, I use
Facebook, I use Twitter.
- And how do you use them differently?
- Well, so I--
- What do you use Facebook for?
That's interesting to me.
- To be honest with you, Facebook,
I used to have a private account,
and now I have people
running it for me, like--
- Your fan page.
- Like a fan page.
But me, I just started to have
a bit more fun on Instagram
because I think it's just
newer and it's more--
- Correct.
- Yeah, and more
for the younger generation, so--
- And what about Twitter?
- Twitter, I have a team
who's running it for me too.
Basically what I put on my Instagram,
it's sent out to what I put on my Twitter.
- Do you engage ever, or
are you just consuming?
- It's just consuming, I would say.
'Cause at the end of the day,
what I don't like is when we lose a game
on a Saturday--
- And people
tell you you suck.
- And people tell you, that's
cool running into that.
But I feel if you lose,
and you post a picture
two minutes after about you enjoying,
I don't know--
- A meal.
- A meal or whatever,
they will say--
- They're like why don't you
fucking focus on the game?
- Why don't you fucking focus
on the game?
And I'm like Jesus
fucking Christ. (laughs)
I'm a human being, so
I need to live as well.
- Uh-huh, fair enough, I get it.
(laughter)
Talk to me about, just
because it's so current,
obviously the US national
team wasn't involved,
but how did you process the World Cup?
Did you go?
Who were you rooting for?
How did you think about it?
Obviously Germany under performed.
England performed extremely well.
- [Audience] Boo.
(laughter)
- How did you, did you go?
- No, I didn't go.
- Okay, did you want to go,
or you just couldn't go?
- No, I did not--
- You had nowhere to fight,
'cause you were salty about
not being in it, right?
- No, because I broke my
ankle four months ago,
and I was focusing on my recovery--
- Respect. Who'd you think
was gonna win, for real?
Who did you think was gonna win?
- If I had to place a bet,
it would be Spain or Brazil.
- Right, and so how did
you think it played out?
What caught your attention most
about this year's tournament?
- I think the team that
surprised me the most
was definitely Croatia.
- Of course.
- Because they have
amazing technical players
but when you see the size of the country--
- It's just no room, yeah.
- Exactly, so that they came that far,
it's like big respect to them.
- Yep, so what about
technology as a whole?
And then I'm gonna open it up.
So for the questions for
everyone in the audience,
you wanna get very nerdy
about proper football,
do your thing, enjoy it.
If you wanna ask me a question
about business stuff, fine,
wherever you wanna go, we're here for you.
Before we open it up to the questions,
technology as a whole,
having an Alexa at your home,
the way you watch TV,
how much TV do you watch?
- To be honest with you,
I don't watch a lot of TV.
- So when you do watch TV, is it sports?
Is it movies, is it
Netflix, how do you roll?
- Most of the time, it's Netflix if--
- And what are you watching?
- I watch 13 Reasons Why
for the moment. (laughs)
- You and a lot of other people.
- Yeah, and then some people
have me watching Love Island.
(laughter)
- Guilty pleasures always do well.
What about gaming?
Do you play mobile games?
Do you play FIFA?
Do you play Fortnite?
Are you doing anything in gaming?
- I used to play FIFA a lot,
and I used to play Pro Evolution Soccer.
But I have to say that that
doesn't interest me no more.
Because, I don't know, as footballers,
we have this weird life.
We go to practice every morning,
and people think we don't
do anything but we
actually do, stretching.
And then we come home,
and I don't have the--
- Energy.
- The energy to
actually go and sit down
and game or whatever.
I just like to chill, watch Netflix,
or talk to friends or meet with friends
and actually connect--
- Live.
- With them, instead of social media,
check WhatsApp, how are you, whatever.
I just like to network
with people in real life,
I think that's what we're supposed to do
still as well, so I like that.
- How do you actually, I apologize,
one more question before I open it up.
How do you think about
your post athletic career?
What are your ambitions when
you're done with playing?
- Well, I started to invest
in some properties when I was
coming here, so I own four
properties now in London.
And I was actually having a
meeting with one of my people,
the companies who work for
me, and we went through it,
and obviously one of these
questions was actually,
what are you gonna do after football?
And I think what I wanna focus more on is
rehab centers because
I was quite unfortunate
through my career with injuries,
and I think there is so much
more space in the development,
the treatment, especially in the UK,
to improve rehabilitation, so that's one--
- Where do you think about living?
Have you thought about that?
- I love Los Angeles, I really love it.
I do like it a lot, but (laughs)
London, definitely,
because I used to live here
for four years and it's close to home.
'Cause my parents are,
obviously they live in Germany,
it's just like one and
a half hour flight, so--
- You're thinking about
splitting your time there.
- Exactly.
- I love it.
Great, who's got questions?
- [Audience Member] I
just wanted to ask you,
when you went to probably the academy
into the German national team,
how do you find the
quirk when you're playing
a lot better players and stuff?
Did you have it affect your confidence?
- Yes, like massively,
it was quite intimidating
because you are in the club,
and they say to you that you're
the biggest talent, right?
So you think, okay, I'm gonna go there,
and I'm gonna rip it up.
But then you actually
play with some players
from different counties, different areas
from the same country,
and it's like, okay,
you have actually players
that are better than you,
and then you start to realize, okay,
maybe I'm not as good or whatever, so--
- Who was the first player
you ever came across,
even if it was when you were five,
or when it was this big jump
where you were like, holy shit?
Even if it's somebody famous
or if it's some person
that never made it, do you
recall the first time you came
across a player that you were
just like, this is different?
- Two players that stood
out, it was Toni Kroos.
- I'm sorry?
- Toni Kroos.
When I played against him in the youth,
I was like, this kid is
something else, and--
- 'Cause of the speed?
- No, not because of the speed,
because I think I'm
quicker than him. (laughs)
And just the way he moves the ball
and it's fluctuating--
- The fluid nature.
- It's just crazy and the
talent, the raw talent he has,
and also his ability to.
Some people probably
don't like me to say that,
but he gets a lot of
steak, which I understand
because of his body language
and the way he carries himself.
- What stood out to you when
you first crossed his path?
- With him, it was just his calmness.
I think I played against
him when he was probably 18,
18, 19, and I think he used to
play for Bayern at the time.
And he was just like, how he
moved the ball and everything,
he actually took the
game in his hands already
and he was 19, and everybody
who ever played football
will know how tough it
is to control the game,
especially when you're a young player.
Because I mean, you
have to have confidence,
that you have other
people to believe in you
to get you the ball and stuff.
And the way he created
the chances and has,
I think he's always two,
three steps ahead of you,
he knows situations--
- The game's playing
out up here.
- Exactly.
That's like the biggest surprise for me.
- Very cool, questions?
Yes, sir.
- [Audience Member] What was
the key thing to overcome
to get around which are
pessimistic when you were working?
- The question is how
were you able to overcome
the inevitable pessimistic cynicism?
At some point, whether you
were 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
you're saying I'm gonna be
a professional football,
the odds of that are quite low.
How were you able to not hear
your friend or your uncle
or a neighbor, I think for a lot of us,
I think it maps to everything in life,
how were you able to shut out the noise?
What was it inside of you,
parenting, results, somebody,
why were you able to always,
'cause there's no way
you end up to where you are
without, at every insecurity,
be able to say no, I'm gonna
get over this hump, versus
I'm gonna go this way, or
I can't get over the hump,
or let me go backwards.
- For me, it was quite easy I think.
Whenever I watched Carter
McGraddon's documentary,
you know he always speaks
about visualizaton?
- Yes.
- And I have to admit, the minute I was,
I had the bottom line on my feet,
I knew, I just visualized it
in my head that I was like,
I'm about to be a
professional football player,
and it sounds weird but
I always had this belief
and I saw myself kicking
the ball in the stadium,
and it was crazy when
I played my first game,
and my parents, they stood there crying,
I visualized that, about, I
don't know, 17 years earlier,
you know what I mean?
- Did your parents look the way
you visualized them 17 years earlier?
(laughter)
- Well, I don't know.
No, but--
- I actually,
you know why I'm asking you that?
I would argue I do a
lot of similar things,
and they're just premonitions,
it's not very clear.
But I always laugh that
the people at the time
look the way they look then,
and I always think it's
funny 'cause 20 years later,
they're much older and it looks different.
It looks different than
what it was in your mind.
- No, definitely.
- I get that.
- And also, like I just said,
when I grew up--
- Were your parents
blindly on board?
Would your mom--
- No, no, no.
I had a lot of trouble when I grew up.
When I moved to this academy, my mom,
she was diagnosed with breast cancer,
and my dad had a lot of problems.
My brother, he was in a lot of trouble,
so I ran from this, not the easiest,
but I always said to myself,
I wanna be the one who
stands up in the family
and wanna make them proud
and I wanna make myself proud
because end of the day,
I only have to prove that stuff to myself.
- When you're going through
those kind of difficulties
at such a young age, was the pitch,
was the field a escape from all the shit?
- Definitely, like I was--
- It was the medicine?
- Yeah, I always felt free
when I was on the pitch.
All the bullshit, what's going
on in the family, whatever,
when I, the minute I step
my foot on the pitch--
- It's gone.
- It's gone, I'm free.
So and then it's funny
because when I had more anger,
or when my parents,
when they were fighting,
two, three hours before a game,
I would play better,
because I was so angry
and I just let it on the pitch.
- I understand.
Questions? Yes, sir.
- [Audience Member] How'd you find,
when you were getting closer
and closer to the game,
when people changing room
and see what goes on,
24/7 on the clock.
As players, how do you feel about that?
- I would repeat that.
It's a great question, thank you for that.
The question is, as fans, we are now,
especially in the new digital age,
yearning for, aspiring,
hoping that it could be
a 24/7 thing in the locker
room after the match.
We wanna watch you eat
dinner after a match
and what you're talking about.
We want that access.
As a player, how do you feel about that?
- To be honest with you,
I have nothing against it
because I love going in the dressing room
and having banter with the boys,
and it's just like so
different from the outer world
because even with some friends that I have
and they don't have to do
anything with football,
they're just so different, like the,
I don't know, the nature
of jokes and stuff,
they laugh about different things.
They laugh about football
as well and laugh,
so it's so different and I
don't have nothing against it.
I'll engage it.
- Let me ask you a question
that I've always been interested in.
Have there been in the
last three, four years,
as this world has exploded,
this always on content world,
have there been teams
that you've been a part of
that some of the players look
down on the other players
that are spending a lot of time
trying to build their brand
on Instagram, trying to
sign entrepreneurship?
Is there an animosity of like,
this isn't the way we should be doing it?
You talk about the fans saying,
hey, why are you eating?
Is there a level of tension
in the locker rooms of
some guys doing three public appearances
and had had a keynote at a tech conference
and isn't playing as well as
the team mate thinks that he should?
Is there a little bit of that old school,
new school tension in the locker room?
- Yeah, definitely, I mean,
you can definitely sense
the difference when it comes
to the older generation,
the players who retire or about to retire,
the 35, 36 year old.
Then you have a player who's 18, 19,
and he just posts every day,
he posts stuff about what he's wearing,
or he's in Selfridges, or
he's doing that or he's,
it's crazy, or what car
he drives, whatever.
And then you can see the older guys,
they say, listen, focus
on football, seriously.
But that's just how it is, I think.
In this world that we're
living in at the moment,
it's a bit run by social media as well,
and if you use it the right way,
you can actually capitalize on it as well.
- Yes, sir.
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
my question's for you, Gary,
I was just wondering
whether you had any advice
for smaller companies when
working with big corporations
and how to not be sort
of taken advantage of.
- Yeah, I mean, the question,
just to repeat it, is,
when you're a smaller
company, how do you not
get taken advantage of
by bigger companies?
Vayner was a very small
company when I started it.
And we worked with the
biggest companies in the world
right away with a little
bit of my reputation.
I have a very interesting answer to this.
It's two fold, first of all,
when you have your own company,
and you have clients, you're in control of
whether you're being
taken advantage of or not.
If you're a client provider,
if you have clients,
you're more than welcome to
pick up the phone and say,
I don't wanna work with you anymore.
And here's the money back,
or I don't want your money anymore.
So first of all, every small
business just needs to know
that that's the great
part of having a business.
You're also in charge, right?
Number two, I would argue for
a lot of small businesses,
the goal is to be taken advantage of.
I think about the first three
to four years of VaynerMedia,
very similar to the way Muhammad Ali
fought George Foreman in Zaire.
I think I rope-a-doped the industry.
I think the industry thought
they were taking advantage
of Vayner, and they were, we
were doing so much more work
for the money they were paying me,
versus the companies that were
much bigger than us when we started.
I also think that's why I let it happen
because that was the value prop,
that we didn't have reputation,
I was a wine shop owner,
now and social media
was not what it is today.
When I started Vayner in 2009,
most of our clients
thought that it was a fad.
So I think two things,
one, you're in control,
and two, it's actually
probably the leverage you have.
And I think too many small
businesses go ideology on this,
they become ideological about it,
and like, oh, I'm getting
taken advantage of.
You're a big boy, it's your
bed, you can sleep in it.
I think you need to use it as an offense,
I think it is the number one thing
that a small tiny business
has over a big business
that needs to make more profit,
that needs to be publicly
traded and then hit numbers.
I think every small business
should try to get taken
advantage of, that's how
they'll become a big business.
(clapping)
Thanks.
Yes, sir.
- [Audience Member] Disregarding catch,
if you had a chance to transfer
to another Premier League,
who would it be and why?
(laughter)
- Answer it, answer it.
- You really put me on the spot there.
- Yes, this is the spot.
- Growing up, I always
applauded the Oslum.
- [Audience] Yes.
(laughter)
You're welcome.
- That was just because
of the history they have,
my dream when I was young, I
grew up watching Pablo Pretnia
and all these players
that went to both TRE,
and they just create so much history
that I think if I was
playing for that club,
I would try everything
to bring the history back
and also make the fans
proud because I know
you guys suffer at the
moment with us in the--
(laughter)
Yeah--
- It's an interesting topic,
I become so fascinated,
so one of the things in
America that I'm spending
a lot of time making jokes
about on social media is
if you live in New York City
and you have a Steph Curry
jersey on that I think you're
a piece of shit, right?
And to me, it's, I think
you're a piece of shit
not because you're a
bad person, but because
I think it's a very interesting psyche of
when you pick a team,
either based on the history
or the current winning status
or when you pick an underdog,
I find it, I'm interested,
I don't understand why,
why do I hate Kobe Bryant until
the last year of his career
when he's a little more washed
up, then I root for him?
Why in every situation, if I
turn on any match of any sort,
something I don't even understand,
if I randomly end up looking,
this actually happened,
one day I'm clicking through,
my son's getting into sports
so I'm trying to get him into everything,
I don't wanna impose my opinions on him,
I want him to taste things,
and there's a cricket match.
I can tell you one thing about Americans,
you don't think they
understand proper football,
we really don't understand cricket, right?
- Same.
- Yeah, I'm like, what the fuck?
Anyway, you're like hitting a bat,
so anyway, it's on.
I literally Google, while the match is on,
to figure out which team is the favorite,
and then I spend the next 10 minutes
desperately rooting for the underdog.
And I'm very interested in,
when I started announcing,
when we opened this office,
that I wanted to pick a team,
I'm fascinated that 99% of people are fans
of the same four to five teams, right,
we all know who they are,
in the same way in the US
whether it's the Lakers
or baseball, the Yankees,
the psyche of people that
wanna jump on bandwagons
versus the psyche of the people that
wanna pick something and pick an underdog.
As a matter of fact, the biggest reason
I'm not 100% locked into the Spurs is
my only criteria for picking
my team was that they
couldn't have won the
championship in the last 40 years.
The problem with the
Spurs is they haven't,
but they're very fucking boujee.
And I'm very confused by
it, it doesn't map to my
Jets and Knicks fandom as
well as I'd like it to.
So I'm still trying to figure my shit out,
but yeah, I just basically
think that all of you
that jump on good teams
when you live in a town
that has a team, that
you're actually a loser.
Questions?
Yes.
- You should support us
honestly, you should support us actually.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- No championship
in 40 years?
- No, no.
- Alright, I'll support.
(laughter)
Yes, Tim?
- [Tim] A very interesting journey
from when you grew up
to where you are now,
was there a particular point when you
decided to take control of your life?
Was it something that
just happened at the time?
- And Tim, before you,
and the question is,
you've been on this interesting journey
for a young man 21 years old.
Was there a tipping point where
you took control of your life?
Based on the interview we've
been doing, I'm curious,
are you coming from the perspective
of the adversity he faced
when he was a youngster?
Add a layer to that question
'cause I'm curious where you're going.
- [Tim] He's obviously very,
you're very savvy about social media.
Is there a point when you
realized you needed to do that,
or is it something that--
- Well, maybe the investments,
not every young man is pouring his money
into investment properties
versus a Lamborghini.
- [Tim] You also run your social media
and obviously now taking control,
so you may not call it leadership,
but you're leading your
whim technically dropped it.
- Well, the first time
I started to realize
that I have to do something
with the money was,
(laughter)
when I moved to London when I
started to play for Reading,
because you have to imagine,
I have my friends and
everybody in Germany,
and then I'm in Vegas, right?
And then my agent calls
me and saying like,
"Danny, I have an offer for you."
And I was like, "Okay."
And he goes, "Yeah, but
it's not in Germany,
"It's like, you have to leave the country
"and your parents and everyone."
And I was like, "Cool, where is it?"
And he goes, "It's a club called Reading."
And I was like, "Where do I live?"
And he goes, "You could live in London."
I was like, "Okay."
And I went, I'm quite
a spontaneous person,
and I think the people in
Germany, they're a bit uptight,
so my character and
the way I carry myself,
I think it fits more
anyways to this city here.
So I was like, you know
what, I'm open to do that.
And so I rented a room in Reading,
and I had nobody calling me,
there was obviously my mom, my dad,
they messaged me, whatever,
but I was just put on the spot,
no car, no bank account
set up yet, nothing.
And I was thinking like, where are all--
- How old were you?
- I was 24.
- Okay.
- I was like, where are all the people?
(laughter)
They don't see me on
TV anymore in Germany,
so I'm not running back no more,
I still have to live and I
have to find, I don't know,
people who are like--
- A social life.
- A social life because
that's the most important,
I always say if I'm not
happy, I don't perform well.
And so then I moved to
London, and I started to--
- Real quick, I apologize.
- Yeah.
- You say if I'm not happy,
I don't perform well.
I assume in the macro because
earlier, in the micro,
you said if my parents are fighting
before the match, I play better.
Is that a macro micro thing,
or was that an evolution
when you were younger,
that worked for you,
but over time, as you grew up, it changed?
- The thing is, obviously
the parents fighting
was one thing, but I was still
happy about my social life.
- Okay. (laughs)
- I was happy about my social.
- So if your social life
is good, you play well.
- I think so.
- I get it, I get it.
Listen, I get it.
- If I'm happy
from the inside--
- Yeah, I got it.
- Then I was happy--
- I respect that.
- And it shows on the
pitch, but when they fought,
I can let the anger out as well--
- I get it.
- So I could get--
- That was the perfect of both worlds.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Your social life is killing it,
your parents are fighting,
you fucking dominate.
- Exactly.
- You got that, okay, got it.
Just wanted to make sure.
- No, but then I started
to hang out with people
who would seem a bit more boring,
(laughter)
who would seem a bit more
boring to the type of friends
I used to have, but
actually more interesting
because he pulled me and say like,
"Danny, listen, you signed a
great contract with Reading.
"Four years, that's
actually a big security,
"and you have to start to
either buy something in London,"
because the city is one of the leading
cities in the world, it's
the capital, whatever.
So the property market, I
think nine times out of 10,
the price would go up and
you have to just generate
another income for you when
you're done playing football,
and I said to him, "Okay,
I never heard about that."
And it worked because
the fans I used to have,
they just didn't advise
me on stuff like that.
So I said, you know what,
I'm gonna rent a place
in West London and see the
area and then after a year,
I will decide where I wanna
invest, and I think that guy,
he helped me a lot and I'll
be always grateful for that
because looking now, I almost
paid all of the flats off,
and I already generate income,
and the places are
rented out, so I'm happy.
That's a good place, I would say.
(laughter)
- Yes, in the back.
- [Audience Member] Hi, I
have a question for Gary.
- Okay, I'll get you next.
- [Audience Member] Is
there gonna be a flashback
or a lashback of social media?
So announcing on Facebook, Instagram,
we now see how long you're staying on it,
are we moving into a cutback on those?
- Yeah, the question was, will there be
a pushback, a lash
against social time spent,
the privacy issues,
I think it's already happened, right?
You already see companies coming out,
look at Apple, Apple is a company
that's not winning in social, right?
There's apps on top of their app platform
but they're not in it.
And so if you're Apple, you're saying oh,
if we build a default device on our phone
that warns you of how much screen time,
there might be a way for us to use that
as a defensive play as an offense, right?
I think the privacy thing
is a really interesting one,
whether it's Brexit or
Trump or many other things
that are going on, I
think we as human beings
don't like to hold ourselves accountable.
And so I do think there'll
be a backlash against social,
but I think it's gonna be more of us
passing on responsibility of things
that we don't want to see in ourselves.
I think parents are very
good at judging millennials
without realizing they're
the ones who raised them
and created the entitlement.
So I think the human condition speaks to,
I believe the people that
tend to win the most in life
are the ones that are the most
willing to be accountable.
And I believe that the masses
do not want to be accountable.
And I do believe that the mainstream media
has a lot of financial reasons
to downplay the digital world
because it's taking their money,
and I think that all these
dynamics are playing out.
So I think there will be a backlash.
Now, I think it'll be
a blip on the screen,
I think that we are going towards,
I mean, when my friends are like,
"Oh, I'm limiting my son's screen time,"
I'm like, "You do know what world your son
"will live in in 15 years, right?"
Just wanna make sure everybody knows,
we won't be going backwards.
Wait till voices mature,
and you're talking to Alexa
like it's your friend.
Wait to AR and VR and all
these things continue,
the robots are gonna kill us in the end,
and so to me, it'll be a micro blip,
three years, six years, six
months, but I think (laughs)
when the whole Facebook Cambridge
Analytica thing happened,
people were posting protests
of Facebook on Instagram.
It was just the most fun
thing for me to watch,
the human condi-- like fuck you, Facebook,
on Instagram, watching those.
And so I think that, I think we will,
but I don't think it means anything
in the inevitable macro
of technology advancement.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Technology always wins.
- [Audience Member] True.
- Because we value
convenience over everything.
We are animals that value
time, subconsciously,
and we will give up
everything, including money,
and that's what we spend
our money on, by the way,
if you play it out so.
Yeah, sir, yeah.
- [Audience Member]
Yeah, question for Danny,
you spent time with both
the German and the US
national team, what makes
the biggest difference
in the national teams,
and then who do you want
to be the next US national team coach?
- Okay--
- The question,
just for everybody watching on camera,
difference between the German
and American national team,
and who do you want the
next American coach to be
on the American national team?
- I think the biggest difference
between the German national
team and the US national team--
- And help me, just for me--
- And football.
- Real quick--
- Yeah.
- How old were you when you
were on the German team,
and how old were you on the American team?
- I played Germany until I was 17,
I'd say 17 or 18.
And then I started to play
for the USA when I was 21.
- Okay, keep going.
- Yeah.
So the biggest difference is definitely
the education in tactically, technically,
because if I look at this, US,
the country is so much
bigger than Germany, right?
And I think the US has amazing athletes,
but they just don't know
how to use their speed,
their power, their strength,
because I would say we
have better athletes
than the Germans, in general,
just like you can see
sprinters and whatever, there's
never a German guy winning,
but they focus so much on
technically and tactical work
that actually invested a
lot of money and research
there as well because the youth cultures,
they then fly to Barcelona,
they go to Amsterdam,
where all the amazing
academies are, and they learn
from them, whereas in the States, I think
because it's not the number
one sport of the country,
they're not really interested
in that, and they don't,
yeah, they don't like to be
bad in something, which now,
since we didn't make the
work up, changed a lot.
I think there's a lot of more
investment going on for American soccer.
- And what about coach?
- Coach, so I think we
have the interims coach
at the moment, Dave Sarachan,
and he's doing an amazing job,
I have to say, I mean
we drew against France,
just a month before they
won the World Cup, right?
And he definitely changed
the strategy of players,
scouting and recruitment, and he focuses
a lot more on the younger players.
And in the past, you had a
lot of politics going on,
for whatever reasons,
which I got a bit slack off
because I came out and said it.
But yeah, there were players who already--
- Past their prime.
Like Germany now, you see
it because they wonder
where I come four years
ago, and people thought
that some players, certain players,
they'll have to start every
game, and that was wrong.
And that happened because with the States,
and it cost us the World Cup.
So I just hope that the
next manager will be someone
who focuses a lot on the
youth and makes decisions
football based, and not political based.
- I think it's, from
somebody from a very outside
point of view in the sport,
but who watches culture very carefully,
I think the most interesting
thing about US football
in the long term is two core things,
one, it's just the popularity
of the sport is real,
if you spend time in
America, 15 years ago,
I never saw a single kid in
America wear a soccer jersey,
it never happened.
Now you see as many kids, six
to 12 wearing football jerseys
as you do see them wear
baseball, outside of
basketball or football
are still number one
but baseball and hockey
and proper football
are now hovering around
the same popularity.
Number two, the Latino
population in the US
is so extreme and exploding
that I think the last names
will look more like Brazil
or Mexico or things of that
nature in 16 or 20 years,
but the resources are there.
It's not religion, like
Lebron's playing basketball,
not defense, and so I think
that's gonna be interesting
to watch over the next 20 years.
Alright, one more question.
- [Audience Member] Hey, so I've known you
over the last 10 years
that you've been super,
one of your cues for culture is hip hop.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] From
our first interview,
you've always entered the big artists
but more recently, you featured
Game and Nipsy and 8boogie.
As you got your nuances
from culture when it comes
to building a business
in America and the UK,
will you align yourself with UK rappers
as a source of lending the culture,
like Gigs and Skepta, Big Shot Jamie,
and my question is, what
nuances will you be looking for
when you talk to those
artists to teach you
things about things here in the UK?
- Yeah, so what my dear friend here
who's known me for a long time
knows I've always really loved hip hop,
as my Instagram over the
last two years has exploded,
in parallel, Mike Boyd, who's
always been close to me,
was freed up to really do strategy for me
and we took approach about 18
months ago to get very serious
about the emerging hip hop
artists that we thought,
in a five to seven year window,
could become the Drakes or Lil Waynes,
and what would that mean
and getting in the trenches of culture.
The question is, am I thinking about that
in a UK lens as well?
And it's kind of interesting
because maybe you've noticed this,
and it's probably why, not probably,
it's why we're sitting here right now.
I've taken the approach in the UK,
and we're opening up
Singapore in February,
we're gonna open up Brazil,
it looks like now in 2019 as well.
It's interesting, my
ambition to get deeper
into proper football,
having a son and daughter
that I want to have a
team and go through it,
knowing that I'm gonna be
here six or 10 times a year,
and because I think authenticity matters,
because I've historically
not gravitated to the artists
that you just mentioned,
I've actually taken
the macro thesis of what
emerging hip hop artists
do for me in a pulse of culture.
In the US, I think the
culture of Premier League
and proper football culture
in the UK and Europe
as a whole is the way
I'm thinking about that.
I'm trying to spend time and
listen and pay attention,
I spend an enormous
amount of time looking,
in the US, I may be World
Star as an Instagram account,
but for the way I'm thinking
about Europe and the UK
in general, it'll be 433 that I'll spend
more time looking at.
And so interestingly,
especially given that
we're sitting here together,
the approach is not
going to be emerging hip
hop artists in the UK,
unless just like everything in my life,
one artist catches my
imagination at the right time,
you know this, almost everything
you love, food, sports,
whatever it may be, it
was one thing that then,
that you fell in love with
and were curious about
that got you deep into the rabbit hole.
So I wouldn't say never, I
allow for a lot of serendipity,
but I also am thoughtful
and have a lot of strategy,
I think the culture of
football here is what
I'm spending a lot of
time on, both selfishly
'cause I wanna suck myself into it,
'cause I wanna get into it.
And because I think it is an incredible
important currency of the culture.
Mary, I saw you raise your hand,
so you're gonna sneak it in.
- [Mary] Yeah, sorry, so
just a question for you,
how can brands drive true
authenticity with influencers
while still retaining commerciality?
So how do we make money
through influencers
without putting our consumers off?
- By giving the influencer 100% autonomy
and eliminating our egos
as brands and thinking that
we know exactly what it
stands for and what it means.
I think what the biggest eye opener to me
in corporate America and
brand world is the level
of ideology and audacity and
ego, like the thought that,
for all the normal people
here, Coca Cola and Heineken
and Adidas think that the brand means
the same thing to all of you.
And that's just laughable.
Everybody here, when I say
the word Supreme or Kentucky
Fried Chicken, are
thinking different things,
disgusting, awesome, rad,
I don't know what that is.
But and so there's an ideology
that brand managers and CMOs
in corporate America have about
what their brand stands for.
If you're gonna do influencer marketing,
what you need to do is you need to
buy sponsorship through
influencers at a good deal.
They know their audience.
He, if he decided he wanted
to do that, I, any of you,
you know your audience, and
so if your interpretation
of this chocolate shake or
sneaker or blow dryer is,
it needs to be funny and snarky,
that's exactly as a brand what you want.
You're giving him, me,
somebody else, money
so that you have something
happen for your business.
Stella wants business, the
best thing for Stella to do
is get out of the way, they,
much like the small business
question, they're in charge of picking it,
you picked the influencer.
You decided that influencer is
somebody I want because she's
so fucking awesome, I want to
give her money so I sell shit.
Why are you micromanaging
her and telling her,
you better use the word great?
I've never used the word, I've never done
a sponsorship deal in my life,
and I have big audiences.
There's a couple of reasons.
It's not how I think about my
brand, and it's not what I do.
But even like the K-Swiss thing,
that's a partnership, right?
But when I signed my K-Swiss deal,
the most interesting
part of the negotiation
was the standard deal, do
you have a sneaker deal?
- Puma.
- Great, so the standard deal is like,
motherfucker, you don't
wear anything else.
I literally at the 11th hour
walked from the K-Swiss deal
because I wanted to wear
whatever I wanted to wear.
If I wanted to wear Air Force
1s, which I like to wear
quite a bit, I didn't want, I
needed the authenticity of me,
I didn't need the economics enough.
And I think that's the best
influencer, not the worst.
Because we smell out bullshit,
we're very, very good at it.
You can trick us for a minute,
but not for an hour and
definitely not for a year.
And so I think that brands
need to check their egos
and get out of the way.
Much like I told that young man,
you're in control.
You can say no, I don't wanna
work with you anymore, right?
Brands don't have to pick the influencer,
but once they pick it, they
need to get out of the way
and let the influencer do their thing.
That's the reason you picked
them in the first place.
Thank you.
Thanks everyone for being here.
Let's clap it up for this wonderful man.
(clapping)
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
Awesome, thank you, guys.
(hip hop instrumental music)